[موسيقى]
كيف تصل المساعدات المقدمه من الامم
المتحده الى مستحقيها في شمال غرب سوريا
تعتمد المنظمه الدوليه ببرامجها المتنوعه
على منظمات سوريه تعمل على الارض وتكون
هذه المنظمات شريكا للامم المتحده بعد
استيفائها شروطا ومعايير معينه بدايه كيف
كانت اليه العمل في شمال سوريا بعد حدوث
زلزال كهرمان مراش تقول منظمات عامله على
الارض انها اجرت بواسطه فرقها مسحا اوليا
لمنطقه واكثر ضربها الزلزال وذلك بالتعاون
مع جهات عامله هناك كالمجالس المحليه
واداره المخيمات وغيرها هذا المسح يرمي
الى جمع معلومات تتعلق بالاحتياجات
العاجله مثل اقامه مخيم جديد وتقديم
مساعدات غذائيه وطبيه وغير ذلك ثم تقدم
قائمه الاحتياجات هذه في هيئات الامم
المتحده المعنيه بالمساعدات المطلو
قبل الزلزال كانت كل منظمه شريكه مع الامم
المتحده لديها قائمه معلومات تتعلق بعدد
المشمولين بالمساعده من سكان المنطقه او
من بين النازحين وبعدد الاطفال والنساء
والمرضى وقائمه بالمواد والخدمات المطلوبه
مساعدات الامم المتحده تكون في مخازن
التابعه لها في مدينه الريحانيه التركيه
قرب الحدود مع سوريا تنطلق شاحنات سوريه
عبر معبر باب الهوى الى تلك المخازن لشحن
المساعدات ونقلها الى سوريا ويجري تسليمها
لكل منظمه شريكه للام المتحده كل حسب
مخصصاتها
[موسيقى]